I'm just gonna come right out and say it
Zac Ephron you stole my career sir it
should have been me as Troy Bolton in
high school musical we both dance act
and sing except one of us doesn't need
to use auto-tune we both performed as
kids we were both born less than a year
apart and we can both rock the short and
long hairstyles I mean look at that
steely gaze we are exactly the same we
are mostly the same
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that encourages viewers to get
you get you get you get you head in the
game if the game is reinterpreting
beloved childhood franchises if you
still haven't figured out what we're
talking about today well then you
probably don't even Disney Channel
original movie bro because today's
episode is all about high school musical
that's right here on film theory we only
tackle the freshest hottest made-for-tv
movie series that haven't seen an
installment in nearly a decade
unless you count sharpies fabulous
adventure pitch I obviously do but in
all seriousness when I was still acting
in theater I was in a big regional
production of high school musical as
Troy's understudy and that gave me
plenty of time to overthink the plot in
between bouts of icing our vocal cords
this guy the thing was my life when I
was a teenager musicals eater show choir
you name it if there was a chance for me
to perform on stage and not have to
interact with the popular people well
boy howdy was I involved and after
spending so much time studying the show
I've always had a bone to pick with HSN
well a few bones actually because there
is no way Juilliard is really gonna send
acting scouts to a random public high
school in Albuquerque to watch a show
written by a student anyway the main
bone I'm here to pick is this the movies
bend over backwards trying to convince
you that Sharpay the quote-unquote
spoiled rich theater diva is the villain
of these stories but she's not in fact
when you stop and actually look across
the entire series Sharpay is like the
only one with redeemable qualities you
hear that Vanessa Hudgens and Zac Efron
your Empire of Fame is built on lies
lies I say you think this is all just a
chip on my shoulder well let's look at
the evidence and bop bop-bop-bop to the
bottom of this case now in case you need
a cram session before this High School
Musical final exam here it is in a
nutshell in the original High School
Musical our heroes Gabriella and Troy
meet when they do karaoke together at a
New Year's Eve party conveniently
finding out shortly thereafter that
Gabriella is transferring to Troy school
actually just the plot of Greece she's a
science nerd who wants to find a new
place for herself at the school and he's
a star basketball player who wants to
find a new place for himself and
Gabrielle his pants on when they decide
to audition for the High School Musical
oh I get it I get the title now even
though they're turned away for being too
late and they didn't prepare anything
they still
Leslee get a callback for the two lead
roles - well wish our parent or twin
brother Ryan or diehard members of the
drama club which now that I'm writing it
out when the villain of your movie is
supposed to be the theatre kid that you
should already be asking yourself some
questions oh no they're gonna put me to
shame with their bah-bah they're pulling
out the viewpoints she's commenting on
my stance sorry the theater kid is
coming rushing back to me anyway Sharpay
and Ryan convinced the drama teacher to
move the callbacks to the same day as
Troy's basketball championship and
Gabrielle is scholastic decathlon oh no
conflict Troy and Gabriella as other
friends think they should choose between
the activities they've already committed
to versus this musical but now they're
the hot protagonists in a made-for-tv
Disney movie so they don't Troy and
Gabriella win everything including the
leads for the musical that Decathlon and
the last shot of the basketball game Wow
growing up is so difficult when you're
young and beautiful the School Musical 2
is pretty much the same thing but over
the summer and with a Country Club
talent show instead of a musical and
High School Musical 3 is pretty much the
same thing as High School Musical 1 but
now they're seniors and focused on
college got it good so what makes
Sharpay the villain well ask anyone who
knows these movies and their arguments
fall into one of three camps one she's a
diva who won't share the spotlight two
she's trying to steal Troy away from
Gabriella and three she's a spoiled rich
girl who expects everything to be handed
to her that's what these movies want you
to believe but if you actually stop and
objectively look at her actions across
these cinematic masterpieces you see
that this could not be
from the tree complaint number one
shar-pei is a diva who won't share the
spotlight very early on in the first
place School Musical we established that
Sharpay is super mean just look at this
conversation oh we're going to sign up -
my brother and I have starred in all the
school's production and we really
welcome newcomers there are a lot of
supporting roles in the show I'm sure we
can find something for you all right so
there's definitely a tone issue but
let's think about what she's actually
saying she isn't discouraging the pretty
new girl from auditioning in fact she
even says that they welcome new people
into the club going so far as to say
that there's lots of roles so she'd be
likely to get one even if Gabrielle is a
complete noob to performing on stage
which let's not forget she absolutely is
this girl is so inexperienced that she
freezes up at the frickin audition I
can't - and try not with all these
people staring at me oh you can't do it
can you well it's not like people are
gonna be staring at you if you're the
lead character in a musical or anything
Sharpay is definitely full of herself to
assume that she'll just be the lead but
then again no one else signs up to
audition for the lead we see the sign-up
sheet and even if they did just look at
the other talent that she'd have to go
up against I want you to know
[Music]
to believe that I couldn't sneeze see
East High not quite the strong starts
program
and yes at first it might seem
underhanded that she convinces miss
darbus the theater teacher to change the
Colbeck since the same day as the
basketball game but Sharpay is just
testing Gabriella and Troy's resolved
see if they're really committed to the
show because let's face it Gabriella and
Troy are committed to other activities
already oh they're friends and each
other
what else does Sharpay have besides
theater and a brother who wear stupid
hats now the idea of testing their
commitment may seem absurd but her fears
are well-founded in High School Musical
3 Troy actively ditches out of the first
act of his senior year show so he can
drive to visit Gabriella while she's
away at another school
Troy Bolton just sent me a text driving
all night try to make it for the second
act
break a leg break a leg what does that
mean dude that's showbiz but you're
going on tonight yeah guys sorry for
completely trashing the months of work
we put into this thing I'd go make out
with my super hot super nerdy girlfriend
don't worry though
I'll be there to grace the show with my
six-pack abs in the second act let's not
forget a true diva would rather not be a
part of the show at all instead of
playing second fiddle to someone else
well in none of the High School Musical
movies that Sharpay ever get the glory
but she comes around in all 40 after
Gabriella gets the lead in High School
Musical Sharpay as fast as her
understudy but still congratulate her
and tells her to break a leg and we find
out in the beginning of hsm to that
Sharpay even gave Gabriella vocal
exercises that helped her in the roll
survey we got off to a rough start but
you really came through
I mean you helped me with the winter
musical those vocal exercises that's
surprisingly gracious for someone who is
supposedly so egotistical now best Forge
at the end of that moves me Sharpay and
Troy are slated to sing together at the
Country Club's talent show her brother
Ryan and his stupid stupid hat betrays a
sister by giving Troy a new song to sing
with Gabriella so that Sharpay can
participate in the one thing that she
was look
or to the entire summer what'd she do
well instead of making a scene in French
the show Sharpay recovers chooses to
sing as a part of the group wins the
star dazzle award as best performer then
graciously gives that award to her
brother who just stabbed her in the back
star dazzle for this year goes to of
course and at the end of play School
Musical 3 when Sharpay isn't chosen for
one of the scholarships to Juilliard
even though her brother and his stupid
hat is we learned that she's gonna help
run the high school's drama department
the following year a role for which
there will be zero glory Sharpay is just
committed to making her school's drama
program great she always wants to be the
star but are we really faulting someone
for wanting to be the best a true diva
wouldn't let anyone near her spotlight
and clearly Sharpay is along for the
ride even if she isn't getting all the
glory complaint number two Sharpay is
trying to steal Troy away from Gabriella
so perhaps a bigger set of sharpies is
that she has goals to date Troy who is
sometimes so what nefarious deed does
she do to win him over does she kiss him
does she push Gabriella off a cliff does
she drugged him and shave off that mop
of hair so she can swim deeper and
deeper into his cool blue winter crystal
like eyes no sharp eyes evil plan is to
get Troy a job at her family's Country
Club then get him promoted so he'll be
paid better and then also introduced him
to members of the University of
Albuquerque basketball team so we'll
have a better shot at getting a
scholarship the following year ashame
and Troy's only bussing dishes all
summer given that he's a potential star
for your alma mater daddy
the U of A Redhawks would be very
interested in it tre is very concerned
about College really that's coach Boehm
these days how dare she
and what insane favor does she ask of
him in return that he's sing with her in
a talent show she's basically offering
you a college education just to sing
with her in the talent show which it
probably should be mentioned when push
comes to shove he doesn't do meanwhile
let's look at what some of the quote
unquote good guys do back in high school
musical one in order to get Troy and
Gabriella 's heads back into the game
their best friend's trick Troy into
saying he doesn't care about Gabriella
in front of a hidden camera and then
they forced Gabriella
to watch
so who's the bigger villain here the
person trying to win over a guy in a
relationship by being nice to him or the
people using hidden cameras to break up
their friends relationship when it
doesn't serve their needs but oh it's
okay for them but Sharpay's actions are
unforgivable yeah I don't think so and
complaint number three shar-pei is a
spoiled rich girl who expects everything
to be handed to her know the rich part
is absolutely right throughout the High
School Musical movies we learned that
sharpey's family owns a resort and uses
a private helicopter but expecting
everything to be handed to her
nothing could be further from the truth
in the straight-to-dvd classic Shar Peis
fabulous adventure Sharpay moved to New
York City to try to make it as an
actress and her doubting father gives
her one month to make a career for
herself or else you'll have to return
home does Sharpay kick and scream about
it no actually she goes and makes the
best of it and tries to network with a
director who voiced interest in casting
her I'm gonna mean with that casting
director get the part be a star and have
a palace
and when she finds out that that
director was actually interested in
casting her dog and not her jerk it
absolutely sucks but she seizes the
opportunity and gets hired as the
personal assistant to the star of the
show who then makes her run errands all
night and scrub toilets does Sharpay
refuse and resolved to destroy the stars
career no once again she recognizes that
getting an in with someone in the
industry is how people get a shot in
show business so she does all the stars
menial chores then destroys her career
the point is across all four
installments of the franchise Sharpay
gets knocked down time and time and time
again losing the lead role getting
betrayed by her brother not getting into
the college she wants getting passed
over for a dog but she never once gives
up on what matters to her she never
stops believing in herself by a dream of
being a star still there
it's just a little bit more of a dream
than a reality and she's even gracious
enough to help others out like Gabriela
and this weird snooty kid with a
performing King Charles Spaniel Shar
Peis fabulous adventure is weeded by the
end of the series she gets the
satisfaction not only of coming out on
top but also of doing it entirely on her
own and that my friends is the most
noble hero s arc that we see from anyone
across the entire series Zeke had it
right the entire time if you actually
get to know her I mean you and the so
called heroes of these movies don't even
let him finish talking about keeping an
open mind to a fellow classmate
well done Wildcats well done that's all
well and good Matt Pat you're probably
saying right now but High School Musical
needs a villain
so who's the villain well you're in luck
because the series does indeed have
someone who is truly spoiled someone who
doesn't deserve the things they have
coming to them and then is ungrateful
for the opportunities that come their
way it is none other than the six packed
auto-tuned wonder Troy Bolton I mean it
starts all the way back in the first
movie when the time comes for Troy and
Gabriella to audition they've chickened
out they only gather enough courage
after it's too late we take these shows
very seriously here at East High I
called for the pair's audition and you
didn't respond free period is now over
but apparently not seriously enough
since miss darbus here's I'm singing and
then gives them a callback anyway Bolton
Montez you have a callback and if you
want to talk about someone who won't
share the spotlight bowl look no further
than Troy Bolton in High School Musical
2 when Troy's invited to play pick-up
basketball with the players on the
University of albuquerque's team an
opportunity I should mention he only
gets thanks to Sharpay his friends on
the high school team asked to go and
Troy doesn't even consider it before he
refuses I don't think that's how they
roll it's a closed practices want you
after work just flat out ditches up and
speaking of being a bad friend he breaks
pretty much every promise he makes to
his girlfriend Gabriella in High School
Musical 2 then uses Sharpay's affections
to get more money and access to people
who can help him out entire
of university boosters we're coming to
see you thanks to me I'll be there later
they'll be thrilled
I'm more interested about what my
friends think of me all in return for
singing a song at a talent show with
Sharpay that he acts like is a huge tour
the entire time and then ultimately
doesn't deliver on he will sing some
other time though with me promise
promise
well sorry mr. swoopy bags didn't mean
to give you an opportunity to pay for
the college that you said you couldn't
afford try is very concerned about
College really that's coach Bolton these
days know fantastic outstanding next
time I see Country Club princess I'm
gonna launch her and her pink hearts
ready to the lake
both the ran buddy speaking of that job
by the way Troy spends most of the movie
worried about money but then spends most
of his time at the job getting others to
completely ignore their duties I'm sorry
I'm late mr. Fulton more Troy's just
slacking off with his friends mr. Fulton
this was my idea she had nothing to do
I generally overlooked your previous
brake violation but then came the golf
course joint and now this two strikes
it is a job you gotta do your job to
earn the money you're gonna have to earn
your way into that college Troy or maybe
you don't because life hands Troy Bolton
whatever the F he wants at the end of
High School Musical 3 it's announced
that Troy will attend UC Berkeley
because he chooses fast fun
but I've also chosen theater yeah Troy
are they letting you play basketball at
Berkeley who did your coach father have
to pay off to make that one happen
because UC Berkeley is a big-time
Division one sport school which for
everyone who doesn't talk sports
translates to these guys are serious
about their athletics in the 2017-2018
college basketball season no starting
player on the UC Berkeley team is
shorter than 6-foot 3-inches
Zac Efron is five foot eight he is
shorter than me which begs the question
how is Troy Bolton the theater
basketball double threat able to manage
that could it be just because things are
handed to him his spot on the basketball
team his job at the Country Club and
let's not forget that he never even
formally auditioned for the show in the
original high school musical if you're
looking for somebody to hate these
movies maybe look away from the
hard-working rich girl and look a bit
more of the popular kid who always gets
whatever he wants whether he deserves it
or not I guess good things come to those
with ABS I'm gonna start doing some
crunches but hey that's just a theory a
film theory and you know as hard as I
tried I couldn't figure out how to prove
that High School Musical was in the same
universe as Breaking Bad even though
Gabriela is a science whiz who has been
moving every year and might be being
chased by the DEA or gust Springs
daughter or something hey if you can
make an airtight connection let me know
because that would be the best theory
ever High School Musical is the prefold
of Breaking Bad in the meantime hit the
subscribe button to ensure that you get
more theories sent to your door that'll
ruin your childhood you can bet on it
bet on it bet on it bet on me and if you
want more Disney ruin for you well then
check out how mallanna and maui are
secretly related along with their pig
that is the box to your left now if
you'll excuse me I do really need to do
those crunches